southwest airline cades on its vaccine
mandate gensake mocks americans worried
over the supply chain bottleneck and the
woke left turns on handmaid's tale
author margaret atwood i'm ben schmerer
this is the bench bureau show
this show is sponsored by expressivevpn
don't like big tech and the government
spying on you well visit expressvpn.com
all of that we're gonna get to all the
news in just one moment first as you
know inflation is running extremely hot
right now and now democrats are planning
to push through trillions of more
dollars in spending which of course is
only going to increase the problem so if
you think that money grows on trees
apparently the way our government does
keep living in that la la land if
however you're a little bit freaked out
about the fact that the central
government of the united states is now
blowing out the currency you might want
to diversify at least part of your
portfolio into gold or silver if you
haven't reached out to birch school to
diversify part of your ira or 41k into a
precious metals ira go ahead and do it
today text ben to 47 4747 get a free
information kit on protecting your
savings with gold i buy my gold from
birch gold they have an a plus rating
with the better business bureau
countless five star views thousands of
happy customers and this month when you
place an order with birch gold you will
get a signed copy of my book how to
destroy america in three easy steps text
ben to 47 47 47 to claim your free no
obligation information kit on holding
gold and silver in a tax sheltered
account plus sending this text is the
only way to be eligible for that signed
copy of my book when you place an order
again text ben to 47 47 47 and protect
your savings today alrighty so in my
latest book the authoritarian moment i
talk at length about how you fight back
against the fact that the institutions
of the united states pretty much every
major institution has been hijacked by
the left how do you fight back against
that and what i talk about is the fact
that the way the left originally took
control of institutions is through a
process that i call renormalization it's
not my term it's a process that was
originally termed by a physicist named
serge gallum his basic idea is that with
of any organization you can reorient the
entire organization and the way you do
this is you create an intransigent
militant minority who is willing to take
incremental steps in pursuit of a larger
goal and then you pressure everybody
who's in the middle to basically cave to
you this is how institutions got
left-wing in the first place and at the
end of my book i talk about the fact
that we can re-renormalize i.e normalize
these institutions by using precisely
the same process lefted except in
reverse
you can unionize all of your friends
inside a particular company and say i'm
not going to that critical race training
theory session we're not doing any of
that
right you can organize all of your
friends and neighbors and say we are not
going to abide by this particular
mandate right this goes back all the way
to high school when you used to say to
your friends well they can't suspend all
of us right if we do this they can't
suspend everybody okay well sometimes
they could but sometimes they couldn't
well the reality is that when people
push back when liberty loving people
push back against predations from
institutions the institutions generally
are then faced with a transactional
choice cost right they have to determine
whether it is worth the while whether it
is worth the time and stress and money
of fighting that intransigent minority
or whether it's better to just go
weapons down
and as we are seeing in today's world
renormalization re-renormalization can
happen and southwest airlines is an
excellent example of this because
basically what happened is that a huge
number of the employees at southwest
airlines said we are not going to abide
by your vaccine mandate and now
southwest has essentially caved
according to cnbc southwest airlines has
scrapped a plan to put unvaccinated
employees who have applied for but
haven't received a religious or medical
exemption on unpaid leave as of a
federal deadline in december southwest
airlines and american airlines are among
the carriers that are federal
contractors and subject to abide in
administration requirement that their
employees are vaccinated against covet
19 by december 8th unless they are
exempt for medical or religious reasons
rules for federal contractors are
stricter than those expected from the
biden administration for large companies
which allow for regular cova testing as
an alternative to vaccination executives
at both carriers in recent days have
tried to reassure employees about job
security under the mandate urging them
to apply for exemptions if they can't
get vaccinated for a medical reason or
for a sincerely held religious belief
the airlines are expected to face more
questions about the mandate when they
report quarterly results on thursday
morning pilots labor unions have sought
to block the mandates or sought
alternatives such as regular testing
southwest senior vp of operations and
hospitality steve goldberg and julie
weber the vp and chief people officer
wrote to staff that if employees
requests for an exemption have not been
approved by december 8th they could
continue to work while following mask
and distancing guidelines until the
request has been reviewed
so basically what happened here is that
southwest looked at its bottom line they
said okay we're going to have to risk
running afoul of joe biden and the
federal vaccine mandates and maybe lose
some federal contracts or we can
continue to be canceling thousands of
flights okay because remember the the
going line is that it was weather
problems that were causing southwest to
cancel a ton of flights and then it
turns out that american randomly had to
cancel a lot of flights you know who
hasn't had to cancel any of their
flights delta
because delta didn't do any of this
stuff
and so southwest has now essentially
backed down because what they basically
said is if you don't want to get the
vaccine apply for a religious
a religious exemption and if we don't
get back to you in time and we still
have these mask mandates that that we
are going to impose but
you know you can abide by those and we
will just continue to pay you and you
will continue to do your job because we
would rather have you on the job than
have to suspend you without pay and then
maybe destroy our ability to even fly
these planes so it turns out that when
you get enough of your own employees to
resist what you are doing
that can have an immense effect on how
these companies are run
american airlines ceo doug parker spoke
with labor union leaders on thursday to
discuss vaccine exemptions american
airlines management indicated that
unlike the approach taken by united they
were exploring accommodations that would
allow employees to continue to work said
the association of professional flight
attendants that's the union that
represents all the flight attendants in
the cabins they failed to offer any
specifics as to what such accommodations
might look like at that time
choosing not to be vaccinated and not
receiving an exemption may still result
in termination said american it's not
planning voluntary leaves or early
retirement packages for those who choose
not to get vaccinated they say we want
all of our team members to be vaccinated
so they can continue working at american
we needed our entire team to run the
airline in 2022 and beyond and are not
looking to reduce head count
but when these companies are put up
against it and they have to choose
between whatever amount of money they're
making from the federal government and
their ability to literally put crews on
planes it makes it very difficult for
them to side with joe biden and you're
starting to see more and more businesses
do that right we announced that we were
not going to be complying with the joe
biden vaccine slash mask mandate
the the vaccine slash testing mandate
this is not something that we here at
daily wire we're going to abide by
because we felt this was a violation of
freedom of association
and basic liberty principles
and could not come from the federal
government well now we have a battle in
san francisco between the san francisco
department of public health and in-n-out
burger so in and out burger for those
who don't live on the west coast indones
burger is one of the biggest chains on
the west coast it is much beloved
and the in-n-out
the the business
managers over in and out said we are not
going to be checking customer
vaccination documents we're not going to
check whether you have a covid vaccine
card before we serve you the san
francisco department of public health
therefore closed in and out on october
14th because employees were not properly
checking for customers vaccination
documentation the burger chain said in a
statement
the restaurant located in san
francisco's fisherman's wharf has now
reopened but indoor dining is
unavailable
in and outside it properly posted signs
of local vax requirements but refuses to
strictly enforce them
their chief legal and business officer
arne wenzinger said quote we refuse to
become the vaccination police for any
government we fiercely disagree with any
government dictat that forces a private
company to discriminate against
customers who choose to patronize their
business
now this of course is a good and brave
and rational decision by in and out it
is simply ridiculous to turn all these
businesses into the vaccine police
that's absurd
using private industry
to cram down government bake the cake
policies is insane no matter what the
bake the cake policies happen to be
it's particularly insane coming from the
san francisco government where if you're
at the upper echelons you can unmask
because the spirit moves you as mayor
london breed once suggested
so businesses are starting to resist and
this is good this is what stops all of
this and you're starting to see this
happen at the local level with regard to
police officers we talked about this
yesterday hundreds maybe thousands of
police officers across the country
are saying we would rather be kicked off
the force and then exceed to your
demands
and then we'll see how you like it when
you're the one picking up the phone and
having to respond to a 911 call where
all those social workers were talking
about hiring why you get those people
out there chicago alderman brian hopkins
he's pointing out that chicago could
lose a thousand police officers over a
vast mandate that lori lightfoot herself
you know she does not abide by any of
her own mask man it's again for the
people at the top of the of the food
pyramid when it comes to
the government they just don't abide by
any of their own rules here is the
chicago alderman brian hopkins saying we
might lose a thousand police officers
over this
we're already short police officers
we're down you know probably about 20
percent uh from where our peak staffing
levels were a few years ago so we're
short patrol officers where we've been
unsuccessful like jurisdictions all
across the country at recruiting young
people to choose careers in law
enforcement we have retirements
happening at an accelerated pace we
can't afford to lose a thousand police
officers we can't afford to fire a
thousand police officers over an impasse
like this right now
now what is amazing about all of this of
course is that democrats are going to
continue to push forward with this the
reason they're going to continue to push
forward with this is because when they
look at the polls what they see is that
most americans mostly or strongly
support vaccine or or indoor mass
mandates and all the rest okay here is
the thing the people who are most
motivated by things like vaccine
mandates are the people who are
resisting them
not the opposite remember an
intransigent minority can make a
difference here everybody who's already
vaxxed is already vast and so while they
may be okay with vaccine mandates
because they're already vast this is not
a motivating factor for them they're not
sitting around each and every day going
yeah man vaccine mandates that's what
we're for but there are a bunch of
people who are resisting the vaccine
mandates and for them this is the number
one issue
right this is something that we need to
understand about when you look at
political polling political polling is
taking your temperature on a particular
issue but one thing that it generally
does not do is ask you the fundamental
question which is where on the list of
issues does this rank so what you'll see
very often is polling support for things
that that are sort of broad left-wing
agenda items and then the left will say
everybody supports this right everybody
wants universal child care and then when
you ask people like on the priority list
where does this rank people like 130th
right the people who who for the people
who are resisting a government mandate
in this particular case this is issue
number one if you're a business owner
and you're resisting a government vacs
mandate
then that is number one issue for you if
you're somebody who is kind of like yeah
vaccine mandates sound kind of good i
mean i've already vaccinated why
shouldn't everybody like that's number
10 issue for you
so what that means is that the people
who are the most passionate can move
everybody else and that is what you are
seeing in real time it's going to have
real effects at cbs chicago reporting
yesterday openly that businesses are
just going to stop moving to chicago
because there's not going to be any law
enforcement when you get rid of the cops
because you're saying it is more
important for the cops to be vaccinated
than it is for there to be cops to
actually answer 911 calls why would any
business located in a city like that
tonight an alert for businesses on
chicago's prime avenue our tara molina
is always investigating and joins us
live along the famed shopping street
tara this could stop some new companies
from moving into vacant storefronts
[Applause]
erica experts tell us there's already
that hesitation and it's not only
because of the continued robberies and
thefts here on the mag mile and across
the downtown area but because there's a
perception right now that chicago just
isn't a safe place to be
okay well that is correct and that's
happening in major cities all over the
country seattle police union president
has now slammed seattle's leaders
over these vast mandates mike solon he's
pointing out that seattle is going to
just lose all of its officers and then
we'll see how much they like these vacs
mandates
we've lost so many people because of the
political betrayal from our elected
officials in this city over 350 cops
gone
because we were once the modeled
reformed agency and then after floyd
these same politicians who invoked this
mandate
ran away from us as fast as they could
for political reasons now it's our
people are desperate to have their voice
heard
and this is strictly about the mandate
okay and he's right about all of this
okay resistance breeds the failure of
the authoritarian state people who
refuse to go along to get along are
going to be the people who end up
pushing back against the regulations in
such a way that liberty is preserved and
this is true on nearly every front now
what's amazing is that practically
speaking practically speaking
there's gonna come a point here where
everybody's just gonna have to let go
and the reason i say that is because
let's say that you even have a vast
mandate in place like israel right you
have these vast mandates in place
how do they even determine when things
are safe or not is a real question so it
used to be that israel when you got off
the test they would do an antibody test
right they would check to see if you had
antibodies for covid and this would be
the way to determine whether you need to
quarantine or not and the reason they
were doing this is because it is quite
possible that you had two shots of the
vaccine and that it had waned so did you
need a booster or did you not need a
booster well now as it turns out that's
a really bad way of determining whether
or not you're immune to the virus we've
known this for a very long time some of
us have been saying this for a long time
that all these antibody tests don't do
bleep okay what you really need is to be
testing t cell and b cell immunity right
the memory cells that's what you
actually need to be testing which is
much more expensive and much more
difficult nobody wants to do that
okay so in the end what it's going to
come down to is just
how many infections there are how many
people are dying how many people are
hospitalized when the numbers are low
everybody's going to be open about it
and when the numbers are high people are
going to start taking precautions which
is called risk assessment
and how we should have been dealing with
this since basically the beginning
he'll get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk about a simple
fact you need to protect your family in
case god forbid something should happen
to you i mean let's say
that one day you are just surveying a
the landscape and you look and in the
distance there's a cloud of dust and you
realize that you have not seen your son
simba for quite some time and you charge
across the savannah and you look down
and there's a herd of stampeding
wildebeest bearing down
on your sun and you jump down you grab
your son you bring him up and then
that's that's when you see your own
brother scar who proceeds to
plunge his claws into you and as you
tumble down toward the stampeding
wildebeest you think a couple things one
i really should have gotten my brother a
birthday gift and two
man i should have gotten life insurance
like shapiro said policy genius makes it
easy to compare quotes from over a dozen
top insurers all in one place why
compare you could save 50 or more on
life insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius it could save 1300 bucks
or more per year on life insurance by
using policy genius to compare policies
those licensed experts and policy genius
work for you not the insurance company
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process that kind of service has
earned policy genius thousands of five
star reviews across trustpilot and
google and eligible applicants can get
covered in as little as a week thanks to
an award-winning policy option that
swaps that standard medical exam
requirement for a simple phone call
getting started is simple head on over
to policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance covers you need and
compare personalized quotes to find your
best price head on over to
policygenius.com slash apparel get
started right now policy genius when it
comes to insurance it's nice and very
important to get it right
okay so as i say if we are talking about
how we get back to normal antibody tests
are not going to be the way to do it
which means it's going to be difficult
to determine whether people need for
example
some sort of of booster shot or not is
according to the washington post
in most cases getting an antibody test
to determine immunity is a fool's errand
infectious disease doctors agree the
test for antibodies also known as
serology tests do not provide the
answers most people are seeking both the
cdc and the fda advise against using
antibody tests to determine one's level
of immunity against covid so does the
infectious disease society of america
which represents infectious disease
specialists while some states including
maryland and south carolina are
conducting targeted antibody testing for
specific purposes no state is prom is
promoting the tests used for residents
to determine whether they have
sufficient immunity or whether they need
a booster shot the test might indicate
the presence or even the level of
coronavir corona virus fighting
antibodies in the bloodstream but
scientists don't yet know what number of
antibodies even provide protection from
covid19
also
you have other parts of your immune
system that activate when you are
reinfected
right this is why if you get a
reinfection from covet after having the
vaccine or after having covered
previously it tends to be much more mild
because your body already knows how to
fight off the disease what does that
mean practically speaking what that
means practically speaking is that all
of these passports don't mean bleep
okay the passports are not going to be
an effective way of ensuring that people
are immune it's not even going to be an
effective way of ensuring people aren't
spreading it because we know that people
who are
that we know that people who are
immune can also spread the virus
eventually practicality is going to
catch up with folks this is going to
become endemic it already is endemic and
people are going to have to go back to
normal
or maybe not or maybe not maybe it's the
push toward the new normal that the left
is pushing right so we have two attempts
at renormalization one is the
re-renormalization i.e people pushing
back in favor of liberty doing
individual risk assessment and
determining they wish to go back to
regular life and on the other hand you
have people who really wish to
renormalize the society along very basic
lines
i'm not going to stop talking about the
fact that the labor shortages we are
currently seeing may be a ground shift
in terms of
how the economy works like forever and
that the left is pushing this very very
hard
okay they build back better plans that
are being pushed by this administration
are driving up not only inflation they
are driving people out of the workforce
is particularly clear right now that
workers are staying out the new york
times is admitting this ben castleman
writing fall was meant to mark the
beginning of the end of the labor
shortage that has held back the nation's
economic recovery expanded unemployment
benefits were ending schools were
reopening freeing up many caregivers
surely economists and business owners
reasoned a flood of workers would follow
instead the labor force shrank in
september there are 5 million fewer
people working than before the pandemic
began 3 million fewer even looking for
work
the slow return of workers is causing
headaches for the biden administration
which was counting on a strong economic
rebound to give momentum to its
political agenda
conservatives have blamed generous
unemployment benefits for keeping people
at home progressives say companies could
find workers if they paid more but the
shortages are not limited to low-wage
industries
instead economists point to a complex
overlapping web of factors many of which
could be slow to reverse so they try to
blame covid itself
but here is the key psychology may also
play a role survey suggests the pandemic
led many to rethink their priorities
while the glut of open jobs may be
motivating some to hold out for a better
offer in other words people have
basically been told it is fine to stay
home and the government will take care
of all of your problems
whether it's unemployment benefits or
whether it's a child tax credit whether
you're talking about government
inflation or whether you're talking
about helicopter cash via the states
people now feel secure in the notion
that they actually don't have to work
betsy stevenson university of mission
economist who is an advisor to obama
says quote it's like the whole country
is in some kind of union renegotiation
i don't know who's going to win in the
bargaining that's going on right now but
right now it seems like workers have the
upper hand yes but if quote unquote
labor has the upper hand you know who
really has the upper hand
the
you know really as the lower hand is
consumers because the bottom line is
when you drive up the price of labor all
of that gets passed on to the consumer
so if you are driving up the price of
wages and then you're not working you're
shooting yourself in the face because
you're going to be paying higher prices
real wages are down this year they are
not up
so the labor shortages are not creating
widespread prosperity they are creating
widespread shortages
and that's being exacerbated by the
crisis at the port
we're now seeing for example that food
shortages are next in the supply chain
crunch according to brendan case leslie
patton and kim chipman writing for
bloomberg quote in denver public school
children are facing shortages of milk in
chicago a local market is running short
of canned goods and boxed items there's
plenty of food there just isn't always
enough processing and transportation
capacity to meet rising demand as the
economy revs up more than a year and a
half after the coveted pandemic upended
daily life the supply of basic goods at
u.s grocery stores and restaurants is
once again falling victim to
intermittent shortages and delays
vivek sankaran chief executive officer
of albertsons says quote i never
imagined we'd be here in october 2021
talking about supply chain problems but
it's a reality any given day you're
gonna have something missing in our
stores and it's across categories
in chicago dill pickle food co-op ran
out of certain dry goods because its two
main distributors haven't been sending
orders in full in recent weeks
early in the pandemic panic buying was
the cause although the food industry was
able to re somewhat rebound the
sustained nature of the pandemic
combined with the slow pace of
vaccination globally and the recent
surge have resurfaced the problems as
general manager latalia mccarthy
the shortages aren't as cute as they
were but
the
ability to actually put things on the
shelves is declining
according to cbs baltimore why are the
shelves at the local grocery store
always partly empty why do deliveries
take so much longer than they used to
why is everything more expensive
the short answer is the supply chain the
long answer is not that simple
according to cbs local we've got a
shortage of workers along the path that
products take from the factory to a
consumer's doorstep creating multiple
bottlenecks in a system that depends on
timeliness to function just as demand
has drastically increased for those
products
okay so the the simple fact that you are
now seeing these shortages and that this
is being chalked up to a labor shortage
and that labor shortage is being seen by
the left as a good thing right that paul
krugman is writing this right paul
krugman nobel prize winning economist
for trade policy who likes to throw
around that title as though he knows
what the hell he's talking about when it
comes to for example government spending
the fact of the matter is that this is
that this is not a bug this is a feature
this is something that people on the
left very much want is fewer people
working it's something they're
interested in now there's going to be
some unintended political consequences
for joe biden
but you can see how the bite
administration is desperately trying to
downplay this and pretend it doesn't
matter we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about your
safety and security at home so i have a
ring alarm security system on my house
when we move from california to florida
first thing we put that ring alarm
security system on the house because
safety is our number one priority it's
the thing my wife cares about most i
agree with her i feel much more at ease
when i'm on the road or away from home
my ring alarm equals peace of mind you
can protect your home with ring alarm
ring alarm is a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install yourself it works
seamlessly with other ring products in
one simple app for a special offer go to
ring.com ben it's the perfect way to
start your ring experience keep an eye
on every corner of your house with
indoor and outdoor cams see what's
happening direct from your phone protect
your home anytime from anywhere with
ring alarm go to ring.com for a special
offer on a ring alarm security kit today
you can build a system that is right for
your home and have it all up and running
in just minutes it's easy to install
yourself ring.com that's ring.com i
don't just use it when i'm on the road
sometimes i mean i have three kids that
are constantly running around our
property sometimes i kind of lose one
like oh where'd they go you pop up the
ring app on your phone and suddenly i
know exactly where they are makes me
feel a lot better go to ring.com ben for
that special offer on a ring alarm
security kit today
so the attempts by the left to downplay
what we are currently seeing in the
economy is not mere political
convenience
it goes to something deeper which is
they would like the restructuring of the
american economy where half the public
just doesn't work
you can hear i mean that and by the way
the what they are attempting to do in
downplaying the cost of this
is unbelievably elitist
as always the democratic party has a
real disconnect between the people who
make the policy and the people they
purport to be speaking for so just as
the leadership of the democratic party
in too many cases is disconnected from
the concerns of its own constituents
this is true in terms of the so-called
economic overhaul i think if you ask
most americans would they like the
economy back from february 2020 the
answer is yes
you mean an economy with record low
unemployment and record high wage growth
yeah that that economy we'd like that
one back but
biden wants to build back better okay so
in much the same way that the democratic
elite insist that defund the police is a
top priority while 80 of black people
say they want to see more cops in the
cities
the same way that the democratic
superstructure says that we must use
terminology like latinx
while the entire hispanic population is
like um i don't know what you're talking
about that's crazy and no one talks like
that
the same thing holds true on economics
and so there's this this vast crazy
disconnect between the white house for
example and even the people it's
purporting to speak for so here is just
a perfect example of this here's jen
saki yesterday she's the white house
spokeswoman saying that like downplaying
the fact that people aren't receiving
what they are ordering right they're not
getting food right they're not being
able to to go to the grocery and buy
what they need here is jen saki down
playing it because of course
she she has somebody who runs the whole
foods for her in in their tesla here
here's shinsaki
it was clear in march of 2020 when
coveted hit that that the supply chains
across the world have been disrupted
even as as the sort of work to fight
back against kobe proceeded
people it was it was crystal clear that
things were not improving on supply
chain people couldn't get dishwashers
and
furniture and treadmills delivered on
time not to mention all sorts of other
things
so why is the tragedy of the short the
treadmill that's delayed
the tragedy of the treadmill that's
delayed yes that is not the i understand
the reporter said the word treadmill but
the fact that you're seizing on that and
you're pretending that increased prices
in virtually every area of american life
even as
you know price boosters like used cars
are actually going down
well
like to downplay that is the crisis of
the delayed treadmill when you are
talking about people who are spending an
increased portion of what they earn on
food and on gas
and that disconnect is astonishing but
to them they don't care it's just it's
the crisis of the late treadmill and
after all they've got a membership in
orange theory what do they care
and she keeps saying this kind of stuff
right here is jen saki talking about how
the 3.5 trillion dollar blowout build
back better nonsense plan how it costs
nothing she just keeps lying to you and
and the american public are not up for
this okay by the poll numbers the
american people are not up for this
according to politico today
as inflation continues to raise prices
of everyday household items americans
are laying the blame at president joe
biden's feet in a new political morning
consul poll 62 percent of american
voters say the administration's policies
are either somewhat or very responsible
for increasing inflation that includes
41 percent of democrats 61 percent of
independent voters and 85 percent of
republicans
only 38 percent of voters and only 7 and
ten democrats say the country is heading
in the right direction
this is bad news for team biden but
they're just going to try and build
their way through this one here's jen's
hockey lying to you
president still believe that bill back
better will not add a dime to the
national debt
correct it won't why would he why should
americans believe that because it won't
go ahead what if taxes that he says he
wants to you know get more taxes in
whatever doesn't happen would the
economy go solar lots of things can
happen what are you you're going to tell
from up there future generations
not even born yet but they're not having
to look for this is that right that's
right and hopefully you'll report
accurate information yourself
hopefully you'll report accurate so it's
not going to raise the deficit at all
despite the fact that we know this thing
is actually going to cost as they
propose to some five trillion dollars
despite the fact that they are going to
have to raise taxes on people who are
not at the top of the income spectrum
you can lie to some of the people some
of the time but you cannot lie to all of
the people all the time and expect that
they are going to continue to trust you
but again the goal here for the
democrats is once you've reoriented how
americans live then they're not going to
remember you lied to them right once
you've reoriented the entire
superstructure of american life then
people are just going to adapt and once
they adapt that will be the new normal
this has been the democratic plan
basically since the 1960s when it comes
to government spending and government
blowouts the basic idea is you get
people dependent and sure they might
resist it first but soon enough they
will stop struggling and once they stop
struggling they will adjust to the fact
that you've shoved that iv line of
benefits into their arm
this is the plan and and meanwhile they
will distract you with all sorts of
other virtue signaling stupidity so that
you are are not paying attention to what
it is that they are doing right that
that is the goal and and by the way if
you're upset about this stuff you know
just let it go as michelin maynard
writes at the washington post today
quote don't rant about short staff
stores and supply chain woes
lower your expectations
just lower them i mean if you lower the
expectations you're fine
right just understand that life is
changing in front of you
and stop whining about it why should you
expect that the grocery stores are going
to be full of the foods that you've
counted on them being full of your
entire life
i mean keep your expectations reasonable
guys and just adjust to the new normal
stop struggling
and that is that is the goal here and
then we get to the woke distraction
politics so the idea is that if we make
your life materially worse at least
we're virtue signaling along the lines
of the things that matter now again the
disconnect is most people don't care
about the woke distraction tactics it
ain't gonna work
democrats basically have an economic
agenda that people don't like
and that is causing enormous snarls in
terms of the economic solidity of the
united states and the supply chains and
all the rest
and they have a woke governing
ideology that appeals to a very solid
small core of people but otherwise
everybody hates
and they have trump
so that's what they're running on in
2022 good luck to them
really good luck to them
and we'll get to the woke governance of
the left in just one second because it
is it is pretty amazing how they're
attempting to distract from their own
failures by simply throwing out red meat
to what they hope is an intersectional
coalition of people who deeply care
about wokeness
the problem of course is that that's a
very small group of people by all
polling data that people care about
wilderness the most are upper-class
white liberals typically women
it's according to david shore a
democratic pollster
it's not black americans who care about
politics
it's a bunch of white college educated
liberals who went to colombia and
majored in women's and gender theory
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that right now gas prices are just
insane i mean if you look at the pump
the price of a gallon of gas is up
dramatically well i'm thrilled to
introduce an incredible app that
everyone who buys gas needs to know
about it's called get upside my
listeners are making up to 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up you just download the free get upside
app in the app store or google play
right now and you use your promo code
shapiro get a bonus 25 cents per gallon
on your first fill up that is up to 50
cents cash back don't pay full price at
the pump anymore get cash back using get
upside just download the app for free
use promo code shapiro to get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your very
first tank some people who drive a lot
are making as much as two to 300 bucks a
month in cash back there is no catch the
cash back gets added directly to your
account you can cash out anytime to your
bank account paypal or any gift card for
amazon and other brands just download
that free get upside app use promo code
shapiro get up to 50 cents a gallon cash
back on your very first tank of gas that
is code shapiro go check them out right
now again free get upside app
and use that special promo code to get
50 cents per gallon cashback on your
first tank of gas already in just one
second we'll get to the woke governance
promoted by the left the the woke social
politics they hope will act as a
distraction from their own bad economic
policy first when it comes to the facts
the daily wire's newest podcast morning
wire has a never-ending supply not only
has it been topping the apple and
spotify charts since its release it is
the only daily podcast that values your
time and the truth and while we are
working overtime to bring you the news
you need to know we need your help to
keep the facts trending toward number
one so subscribe and start listening now
to morningwire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts leave a
five star review if you like what you
hear you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so if the democrats cannot buy you off
with their bad economic plan then maybe
they can buy you off with a little bit
of wokeness and so
over the course of the last 24 hours a
major magical thing happened
the u.s
department of health and human services
has now commemorated the first female
four-star officer and first female
four-star admiral of the u.s public
health service commission corps
okay isn't that amazing a woman is
actually now a four-star admiral of the
u.s public health service commission
corps now you think that being a
four-star admiral means that the person
served in the military for a long time
that's not what we're talking about
since basically the late 1980s when you
name somebody the head of this
particular department the u.s public
health service commission corps they're
ceremonially made a four-star admiral so
it's not like they served all the way
through okay put that aside first female
right so you're thinking yourself wow a
woman
historic historic woman uh the woman's
man
so yeah there's that
so a more accurate headline would have
been man named sixth man to be
a four-star admiral of the u.s public
health service commission corps that
would be the more accurate headline
because what we're talking about is a
person named rachel levine who used to
be the secretary of health
in pennsylvania when he who is a
transgender woman
i only use biological pronouns on this
show because they're the only pronouns
that are objectively verifiable by
reality as opposed to whatever is in
your head at the moment
when when
this man rachel levine
was
was the secretary of health in
pennsylvania and talking about
nursing homes and and forcing people
with cove back in nursing homes
simultaneously removing his mother from
a nursing home and putting his mom
somewhere else
that person got elevated to the federal
government
very rare radical on policy but the
chief qualification and the thing that
was in all the headlines was the
person's transgender status so this is
very important i know that you cared
more about like health and human
services but it turns out the body
administration is very concerned about
men who say they are women
being treated as though they are
historically women
in being named to
offices like this so that is that is
super exciting stuff
meanwhile on a more important level
new york city has now passed a
resolution directing the health
department to work toward a racially
just recovery from the coronavirus
pandemic they've declared that racism is
a public health crisis in new york city
now
that used to be that sort of language
used to be kind of like a throwaway
piece of language okay well everything's
a public health crisis poverty is a
public health crisis lack of education a
public it used to be a term that just
meant a thing that's important to me and
the left does a lot of these sorts of
terms
there are terms where it just means it's
important to me so it is a public health
crisis or it is a climate emergency
right
they use language that is it's not
supposed to carry content but it just
means i care a lot about this thing so
public health crisis was just a term
they would throw out there to mean i
care more about this thing
and this kind of fungibility in
terminology is very common on the left
it's why they will treat it as though
redistribution is an element of freedom
when it's actually an element of
coercion in any case
we now know that when you declare
something a public health crisis what
you actually mean in terms of actual
content of the term is you can take
absolute control over people's lives
because we've seen over the past year
and a half that public health crisis has
been the rubric under which quote
unquote
experts have taken control of every area
of your life from your business to how
you school your kids to how you walk
around in public to whether you go to a
restaurant so now when you have an
entire city declaring that quote-unquote
racism is a public health crisis and
racism will never be solved okay because
it turns out that racism can mean
anything from racist policy which again
new york city cannot name because there
are no racist policies in new york city
directed on the basis of race that would
be federally state and locally illegal
if you're saying racism is a public
health crisis that's again like saying
poverty is a public health crisis
conditions that are endemic
to the human existence
things that will never go away right
because there are always going to be
racists among us
and in the leftist definition which is
that there are going to be disparities
and disparities our evidence of racism
disparities will always be among us so
long as that is the case we need
absolute control racism as public health
crisis is a way of saying until everyone
has an equal outcome regardless of race
even if the inequality is not due to
raise they must have an equal outcome by
race until that happens we should take
absolute control of every era of your
life because public health crisis no
longer means we care a lot about it now
public health crisis means excuse for us
to control everything you do
the new york city board of health
according to the new york times has now
declared racism a public health crisis
passing a resolution that directed the
health department to take steps to
ensure a racially just recovery from the
coronavirus pandemic now as always as
soon as you add a modifier to the term
justice or just
what you mean is not justice if i say
social justice i mean individual
injustice i mean we are now supposed to
determine whether it is good for the
group that you get individual just
treatment
if the resolution calls on the
department to work with other agencies
to root out systemic racism within
policies plans and budgets on a wide
range of matters that affect health
including land use transportation and
education
it also directed the department to
improve data collection practices and
examine both the health code and its own
history for structural bias what they
mean by terms like systemic racism is
anything that ends with a disparity and
what they mean by structural bias is
anything that ends with a disparity okay
all of these terms mean the same thing
any time there's an inequality and
outcome this must be tracked up to
systemic racism or structural bias or
something and the only way to fix that
is through some sort of actual racism in
policy
that reverses the effect of the
supposedly unjust system
dave shakshi the department's
commissioner is also one of the 11
medical experts who sit on the board at
a meeting on monday he noted the board
was founded amid epidemics of yellow
fever cholera and smallpox in the early
1800s advances in sanitation and
understanding the links between
environmental factors and health helped
curb those diseases he drew a parallel
to the current pandemic and its outsized
toll on communities of color
why do some non-white populations
develop severe disease and die from
covet 19 at higher rates than whites he
said underlying health conditions
undoubtedly play a role but why are
their rates of hypertension diabetes and
obesity in communities of color the
answer does not lie in biology
structural and environmental factors
such as disinvestment discrimination and
disinformation underlie a greater burden
of those diseases in communities of
color so again understand what he's
saying he is saying that if people are
not dying at the same rate and we know
why they're not dying at the same rate
because it turns out that fatter people
die of covet more
right people with hypertension thigh of
covered more people with diabetes diet
covered more and it turns out that not
every population has those diseases in
similar fashion
it it now that means that it's not about
race he says even if it's not about race
it's about race because we then have to
look to the underlying reason why too
many people of color have hypertension
or diabetes or our fat
right then we have to look to the
underlying reasons and we can't look to
how people are individually making the
choice to get fat right we can't do that
we can't look to why so many people are
eating fast food as opposed to
not going and just getting some
vegetables from the store we can't do
that we have to look at the fact that
there is inequality in outcome
in health outcomes and we immediately
have to chalk that up to the system
which means we need ultimate control to
create a completely level utopia
this doctor said the coven-19 pandemic
must render unacceptable that which has
been condoned for generations wait who
condoned it who condoned that people are
fat and have hypertension and have
diabetes who's condoned this by the way
they're wide differentials in class
among white americans on this
so think about race right poor white
americans tend to be fatter than richer
white americans on average
they tend to have more health problems
on average is that us condoning it and
when it comes to health problems is that
the system or is there an intervening
factor namely whether you choose to diet
and exercise which it turns out is on
you okay this is very similar to the
argument that when you look at poverty
in communities of color and then people
on the conservative side say well one
factor in the increased poverty in these
areas has to be single motherhood right
people who are getting knocked up and
then having a baby without a husband in
the home or a father knocking somebody
up and then running away
right
and then somebody said yes but why are
they doing that well since i don't
believe that human beings are simply
widgets responding to
environmental
and so socioeconomic circumstance and
that human beings actually have the
ability and responsibility to make good
decisions which by the way is the
predicate for any sort of rational
politics because otherwise you're just a
social engineer
if you believe in any sort of consent
consent-based politics you have to
believe in the inherent ability of
people to make basic life decisions if
you believe in that then that means that
you should be looking to individual
decision making to alleviate the
consequences of these decisions but now
they're saying you can't do that right
you need the experts who somehow are not
creations of their environment and
socioeconomics the experts have magical
free will that has descended upon them
but the poor schlub who's living in
harlem that guy has no free will
according to these geniuses
and once you declare everything a public
health crisis like racism this means
unending control forever and this this
is both the promise and it is also the
the bribe that democrats are now handing
out we will as always we will solve all
of your problems and we will declare
that you are not racist if you go along
with us in this
right we will alleviate all
responsibility from you both personally
and morally
if you go along with us on all of this
now
there's a threat right the threat is if
you don't go along with us on all of
this and we'll just
outlaw you right we'll just go directly
against you we'll try to
we'll just we will attempt to destroy
you and and destroy your life
the new york city health department said
its resolution was one of the first that
was tied to specific directives those
include making recommendations to the
mayor's racial justice commission and
establishing a data for equity working
group designed to ensure the department
applies an equity lens to public health
data and educates other agencies on how
to do the same again equity lens just
means any time there's inequality we're
going to talk that up to the system
guess who's in control of the system us
we get to fix it okay and if you don't
go along with any of our agenda we will
just cuddle the living crap out of you
we will just cudgel you
okay which is why the i will say the
most enjoyable story of the day is the
targeting of margaret atwood so margaret
atwood of course wrote the wildly
overrated
sci-fi dystopian novel handmaid's tale
right she was used as the the
sort of
icon of the trump era because of course
trump here was all about sexism okay so
margaret atwood made a mistake what was
her mistake
she tweeted out aps called why can't we
say woman anymore
because all sorts of people on the left
have decided that wokeness must take
into account the fact that men give
birth now if you're a rational person
you're like nope that is not a thing if
men gave birth that would be very
difficult as it turns out to press a
baby through a urethra
or through a butthole it turns out
that's very difficult to eject a baby
through either of those orifices you
actually need a female vagina in order
to make that happen okay but if you
point that out
then people on the left go nuts margaret
out pointed that out
and so the left came after her
which is quite enjoyable she was a
feminist icon until she assumed that
women existed whoops
so mix amanda jete knox tweeted i'm
disappointed you shared this because
it's factually untrue we can still say
woman and we can also say people when it
makes sense to use more inclusive
language i'm non-binary i also
menstruate and gave birth to three kids
saying people with period periods
includes women and me
um
no you're a woman you're not non-binary
i'm sorry to tell you this that
non-binary is not a category unless you
are actually intersex you're not
non-binary you are that that's in your
head you're a person who menstruated and
gave birth to children you're a woman
done
tanya tuggak tweeted out i didn't know
margaret atwood sucked transphobia sucks
the people commenting on her post should
be enough proof you're the one on the
wrong side of history please glob don't
let me become a harmful crone everyone
call me out when i get crusty and these
are these are delightful delightful
human beings so it is uh it's exciting
stuff to watch them just erase margaret
atwood now she's she's crossed the
cancel culture and the cancel culture
will come after her by the way at
netflix the netflix co-ceo is already
starting to walk back his support for
dave chappelle
he said he screwed up in his efforts to
communicate with employees who were
overset over dave chappelle's new
special
he said in an interview quote what i
should have done is led in those emails
with humanity i should have recognized a
group of our employees was really
hurting
to be clear storytelling has an impact
in the real world sometimes quite
negative
we have articulated to our employees
that are going to be things you don't
like they're going to be things you
might feel are harmful but we're trying
to entertain a world with varying tastes
and varying sensibilities and various
beliefs and i think the special was
consistent with that
okay so he's already backing up
and so the alternative to bad economics
from the left is bad social policy from
left and here's the thing nobody likes
that stuff this stuff is not
particularly popular the only people it
is popular with
are people who wish to delude themselves
into believing that they are victims in
american life
and if you wish to delude yourself into
believing that you're a victim in
american life you can do it i mean a
huge number of people listen the
incentive structure in human thinking is
always to believe that you're a victim
of outside circumstance and that
whatever hardships you experience in
life have nothing to do with you and
nothing to do with reality they simply
have to do with other people
discriminating against you
and there's a new gallup poll that kind
of demonstrates this it says that
women's satisfaction with the treatment
of their gender in the united states is
now at a record low
apparently only 44 of women say they are
satisfied with the treatment of women in
society 44
and now i just i'm going to point out
here that women in american society are
treated better than women in any society
anywhere on earth for all of human
history
just as an example
right now here are doctoral degrees by
field and gender in 2020
okay in education women outnumber men 68
to 32
overall in all fields doctoral degrees
women outnumber men 53 to 47
in master's degrees women outnumber men
six to four okay they outnumber them 60
to 40 percent
women outnumber men in total graduate
school enrollment
59.7 to 40.3 percent
and yet women are saying that they are
wildly mistreated in american society so
again the left is trying to say that
we've got this economic plan don't pay
attention while we restructure
everything
also we have this woke plan to take
control of your life but we will give
you a perception of victimhood okay well
if you choose to buy into that then i
suppose you can i just don't think it's
gonna make for a very happy life i think
in fact it's going to make for a very
unhappy life but maybe that's the point
you can be on you can be happy in your
unhappiness maybe that's what the left
is is finally betting on here you can be
happy with the breadlines as bernie
sanders suggested you can be happy with
the belief that you're a victim in a
society where you clearly are not one or
you can be an empowered human being
making individual decisions that make
your own life better and the people in
your community make their lives better
as well those are your choices there's
no third choice already we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content in the meantime go check out
the michael moles show that's available
right now i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
a man without any military experience
becomes the nation's first female
four-star general the cdc accidentally
admits that abortion is infanticide and
the washington post tells you to stop
complaining about the supply chain
prices check it out on the michael
knowles show